it is that time of year medicare's
annual enrollment period and rocky is
live inside the call 8 phone bank where
alignment health plan is answering your
questions hey rocky
hey mercedes yeah alignment health plan
is here to answer your questions because
i certainly could not risk groggs with a
lyman health plan you guys have been
here for a full year now officially so
tell us a little bit more about
alignment health plan because people
have options no thank you so lightman
health plan is an award-winning
mission-based company that started here
last year as we talked about in clark
county we're very excited this year
we're going to open up in nye and also
up in washoe counties and then we're
bringing in two new plans that we're
super excited about as well a c-snip
which is for that heart and diabetes
person and then a duel which is that
person who may have medicare and
medicaid out there so we're bringing in
a full portfolio and we're just super
excited to be here well thank you so
much for servicing the valley for us so
let's talk about what that annual
enrollment period is i think that's the
you know the biggest question the main
in question right yeah that for sure is
so we're right in the middle of it right
now it started uh october 15th and we're
going to run all the way till december
7th so obviously it's a very important
time of year for folks to be able to ask
those questions and kind of get the
answers that they need that's why we
have a team like this here from tyler
insurance today so that we can have them
call in and they can feel like they're
talking to a local person that they are
instead of you don't know who you're
going to talk to when you call in one of
those other numbers so we're very
excited to be able to help them answer
all their questions today definitely and
i've been hanging out with these guys
they're so nice so you will have a great
time talking to them and getting your
questions answered next question here
what is the medicare advantage plan so a
medicare advantage plan i kind of refer
to it as that all-in-one plan so it
takes that medicare part a and that part
b
also prescription drug plan it just kind
of bundles it all into a nice neat
package but that's not the best part the
best part is all the extra benefits that
is in it stuff like transportation like
with alignment you can get a two crowns
per year for a 20 copay you could it's
just amazing what they put in here
anymore to really take care of the
member and to really watch out for their
health that's awesome and you know talk
to the community a little bit why should
they call these these calls are these
phones right now well i kind of alluded
to that right now their their tv and
their their mailboxes are full of stuff
and all of them seem to be these 800
numbers that we don't even know where
they're rigging to and what kind of
agent they're going to get all these
folks live here in las vegas they they
know this market they know what the
provider groups like one of our key
provider groups which is p3 health
partners they know about that they know
about all the things that these folks
need to know about and i just love that
they live here and work in this market
absolutely rick thank you guys so much
for all your hard work today again the
phone bank is till 7 pm so give that
number a call 702-650-1101
i'll send it back to you thank you rocky
great information we're going to check
back in with you later on in the hour in
las vegas now